[Música]
quién es el juez
el juez es dios
porque es dios
porque él decide quién gana o quién
pierde no mi oponente
quién es tu oponente
él no existe
porque no existe
es simplemente una voz discrepante de la
verdad que dijo
vivimos en un mundo polarizado o somos
blancos o somos negros y cuando somos
blancos no hay más color que el blanco y
cuando somos negros no hay otra verdad
que la del negro
pasamos la mitad de la vida defendiendo
verdades que creemos que son válidas que
las tomamos como nuestras luego pasamos
la otra mitad desmintiendo postulados
que categóricamente rechazamos lo que
consideramos erróneo falso incierto
lo cierto es que la verdad como una nube
abstracta que está arriba en nosotros y
a la que nos acercamos a través del
pensamiento humano es incierta para
nosotros nos acercamos mucho a veces y
casi tocamos la verdad con la punta del
índice pero de la misma forma a veces
nos alejamos por completo de esta
vaporosa nube por ello desde las
civilizaciones más antiguas se entendió
que el pensamiento debía construirse a
partir del don que nos hace humanos
la palabra
el lenguaje es la herramienta cognitiva
que nos permite ordenar el pensamiento y
cuando ordenamos el pensamiento
ordenamos el mundo y así fue como
nacieron los primeros intercambios
dialécticos entre dos o más personas que
se sentaron a discutir sobre cosas
establecidas y sobre incógnitas no
resueltas
el intercambio de ideas unió pero
también polarizó a los grandes
pensadores de la época antigua y ante la
propuesta de dos verdades donde
solamente una clave nació un ejercicio
increíble
el debate
cuando pensamos el debate en automático
pensamos en discusión en pelea en bandos
divididos o pensamos en estas figuras
acartonadas que protagonizan la vida
política del país cuya mayor preparación
se circunscribe a la presentación de
fotografías comprometedoras del
contrincante a la exhibición de
encuestas que los pone a la cabeza en
una contienda o incluso a la hábil
creación de insultos para sus
contrincantes la verdad es que el debate
no es ninguna de las anteriores el
debate es una herramienta pedagógica
indispensable para forjar en los
estudiantes el pensamiento crítico
cuando le enseñamos a un niño debatir no
le enseñamos a pelear el debate es igual
que las artes marciales debe usarse para
fines pacíficos
pero cuando logramos obtener la atención
de un niño y le decimos que sus
creencias que sus gustos que sus
preferencias pueden ser defendidas más
allá de estos postulados que nacen del
capricho por ejemplo porque sí por qué
no
cuando a un niño se le enseña que lo que
piensa es válido y que él o ella tienen
toda la libertad de pensar lo que
quieran pensar pero que siempre hay que
validar este pensamiento a partir de
razones entonces estamos educando a
niños que en el futuro serán más audaces
para los retos de la vida niños que
serán más libres de pensamiento más
empoderados más fuertes
ahora más allá de la justificación
pedagógica les voy a contar cómo esta
herramienta puede cambiar vidas así como
cambió la mía un verano de 2013 una niña
de 17 años sin ninguna experiencia en el
debate competitivo se cruzó con una
convocatoria para participar en el
concurso estatal de debate político y
así sin ninguna experiencia pero con
muchas muchas muchas ganas de hacer las
cosas bien consiguió colarse en el más
alto peldaño de la premiación después de
ese torneo vinieron los demás los
nacionales los interinstitucionales los
mundiales los de invierno los de verano
y la verdad es que la competencia era
dura las mentes más brillantes del mundo
de habla hispana se reunían
constantemente a construir puntos en
cada torneo para conseguir la mínima
oportunidad de clasificar una ronda más
y una ronda más
pero no todos eran puntos emociones o
posturas
también eran los viajes los intercambios
culturales la gastronomía las desveladas
de estudio las madrugadas corriendo a la
universidad cede para no perderte la
primera ronda del día el debate también
eran los cafés con los amigos peruanos y
chilenos y colombianos y españoles
el debate también era dormir tres horas
por noche producto del jetlag y correr
todas las mañanas a tomar el único tren
que salía del centro de la ciudad hasta
la universidad de córdoba en españa' con
una temperatura encima de 47 grados
centígrados y un sándwich a medio
preparado en la mano o por ejemplo
también era caminar por toda la séptima
carrera de bogotá esquivando vendedores
de chocolates a los que venden minutos a
los artistas urbanos a los que venden
las clásicas pulseritas amarillo con
azul con rojo no interrumpir las
carreras de cuyos y procurar no pisar
nada de lo que los ambulantes colocaban
a lo largo de la calle
el debate también era caminar descalzo
por las heladas aguas de viña del mar
con las gaviotas adornan un cielo que
así espejo con el pacífico y que solo
pablo neruda describía correctamente
el debate también fueron amigos vuelos
aeropuertos turbulencias fiestas el
debate son las muchas medallitas
colgadas en la esquina del espejo frente
al que me peino todas las mañanas los
reconocimientos apilados en una carpeta
de cartón en el escritorio las cosas que
al final de cuentas son solo eso cosas
artículos que están y que no pasaría
nada si no estuvieran los títulos en
cambio son los que sí saben y que
también pesan bastante las tres veces
campeón estatal de debate político me
dicen a veces
la campeona de debate asambleísta en
otras ocasiones
y esas palabras saben mucho saben a las
horas de desvelo que hay detrás de cada
campeonato saben a los libros devorados
para entender todos y cada uno de los
temas saben al café amargo que mantiene
despierto a los seres humanos que
estamos cansados sabe a las manzanas que
a fuerza me hacía comer mi mamá para no
desmayarme de los nervios se sienten
como las muchas hojas y muchas plumas de
todos los colores que invadían la barra
de la cocina de mi mamá y que además
siempre fue mi lugar favorito para
estudiar se siente como los tobillos
lastimados después de estar muchos días
de competencias sobre tacones de 15
centímetros o como las páginas que
siempre me gustaba combinar con el color
de mi vestido o como el pino
universitario de mi alma máter que
siempre usaba del lado izquierdo muy
pegadito el corazón
y después qué pasó
el debate fue una oportunidad laboral
la oportunidad de construir un puente
entre lo vivido y lo que podía compartir
un puente para enseñar para intentar
incidir un poquito aunque fuera en el
pensamiento de muchos jóvenes que
estarían al frente de mi clase la
oportunidad llegó y la tomé y la he
vivido al máximo agarrándome de cada una
de las experiencias que están en mi
pasado para poder transmitir la emoción
y la pasión que significa el debate
competitivo y quizá solo si logro hacer
bien el trabajo todas las cabecitas que
pasan por mi aula de clases salgan más
revolucionadas más preparadas para
confrontar las verdades que nos quieren
imponer
quizá esas personitas que veo sentadas
en los pupitres sean los rostros de la
pregunta de la crítica al día de mañana
tal vez si y sólo si hago bien mi
trabajo estas personitas tan especiales
a las que llamo alumnos en el futuro no
muy lejano estén protagonizando los
cambios la revolución que necesitamos
[Música]